رب العالمين
والصلاه والسلام على رسوله الكريم وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد
فقراءتنا موصوله
في كتاب رياض الصالحين من كلام سيد
المرسلين
للحافظ ابي زكريا
يحيى ابن شرف النووي رحمه الله تعالى رحمه
واسعه
في الباب الاول
باب الاخلاص واحضار النيه
رياض الصالحين
‏and
intention in all acts of worship in
behaى
we mention before that all actions every
one of them every act of worship is
predicated
لا اله الا الله
محمد رسول الله
صلى الله عليه
[Silence]
‏and ch
and
of
sincerity and of intentionality that
every act of worship has to be
intentional
at the narration here we have narration
on
سعد بن ابي وقاس
سعد بن ابي وقاس رضي الله عنه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
صلى الله عليه
‏virtue companions hold just the
deree ofe that propets and messengers so
for instance if we were to
are 124000
prophets who are the best among them
those 315
who were chosen
2ر
العزم من الرسل
الله سبحانه وتعالى
خليل ابراهيم عليه السلام محمد صلى الله
ممد صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
رضي الله عنهم
‏yitce
minion
introductionally
acceptition
من راى النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم مؤمنا به
ومات على ذلك
صلى الله عليه
‏wasever
him disbelief and later believed after
no he met him as a believer and then he
died upon belief he died a that is the
bare minimum of what a companion is but
not all of those companions are the same
level and so when we look at the virtue
of
رضي الله عنهم
[Silence]
مهاجرينص
اهل بيعه الرضوان
صلى الله عليه وسلم
سوره الفتح
بيعه العقبه
صلى الله عليه وسلم الحديبيه
عثمان
الحيج
‏people
the are those
10 comparation
بكر عباس سعد زيد
صلى الله عليه
ع في الجنه
خلفاء
ابو بكر الصديق
رياض الصالحين
امام الحافظ النووي رحمه الله
[Silence]
في الجنه
عمر بن الخطاب رضي الله عنه
سعد بن ابي وقاس رضي الله عنه سعد بن ابي
وقاس
‏was
صلى الله عليه وسلم
هذا خالي فليرني الرجل خاله
خال
سعد بن ابي وقاس
[Silence]
الله عليه وسلم
سعد بن ابي وقاس
الله سعد بن ابي وقاس
صلى الله عليه وسلم
بن الخطاب
الكوفه
الكوفه عراق
سعد بن ابي وقاس
الكوفه من كف
رضي الله عنه
وقاس
ان شاء الله يقول عن ابي اسحاقيا
ابو اسحاق سعد بن ابي وقاس
وقاس
مالك
السعد ابن ابي وقاس
سعد ابن مالك
سعد بن ابي وقاس مالك بن اهيب بن عبد مناف
زهره ابن كلاب بن مره
صلى صل الله عليه وسلم ابن كعب بن لؤي
القرشي الزهري رضي الله عنه احد العشره
المشهود لهم بالجنه رضي الله عنه
ان شاء الله والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم
على نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين
والحمد لله رب العالمين وجزاكم الله خيرا